The anomaly detection approach involves
first developing a model of normal or
legitimate behaviors by collecting
data from the normal operations of
the monitored system and network.
This is called a training phase.
Once this model exists,
the observed behavior is compared
with this model in order to
classify it as either legitimate or
anomalous and
this is the detection phase.
A variety of approaches are used to
construct such depression model.
The statistical approach, process
data into metrics or measures and
then apply univariate, multivariate or
time series analysis to view a model.
The knowledge based approach
uses expert knowledge to encode
legitimate behavior into a set
of rules as the detection model.
A machine learning approach uses data
mining and machine learning techniques
to automatically learn a model
from the training data.
When we compare these approaches,
we need to consider both efficiency and
cost.
Efficiency here means how fast we can
learning a model from training data, and
how fast we can apply the model
to the observed data to determine
whether it is anomalous or normal.
The cost of detection here means, how
much data do we need in order to view
the model and apply the model, and how
much completion of power it is required?
For example,
typically a machine learning based
approach required a lot of data.